most people don't know what their  purpose is but i do believe that it is  out there for everybody and i think that  part of the beauty of life is the  pursuit of finding that this idea that  once you find it then you continue to  find it like you iterate on it or you  remain open to it changing or morphing  in certain ways and the search for it  is you know yes prayer meditation and  all of that but ultimately it is an  inside job like you have to become  integrated with who you are you have to  get to know yourself and it's only when  you know yourself well enough that you  can  determine okay i have to of course  correct and here's how i get more in  alignment with like my energy and paying  attention to the way the universe  responds to that so you can you know  make those fine-tuned adjustments that  that lead you in that direction that you  seek